[Musique]
129 129 femmes sont mortes sous les
coups de leur conjoint ou ex conjoint
depuis le 1er janvier 2019 c'est ça fait
déjà plus qu'en 2010 huit ans on en
comptait 121 une des féminicides que le
gouvernement veut tant digues et pour
cela il a lancé un grenelle contre les
violences conjugales on en parle avec
deux invités en plateau puisque les
conclusions locales 1 de ce grenelle ont
été remises aujourd'hui marielle sabina
bonsoir alors vous êtes la déléguée
départementale aux droits des femmes et
à l'égalité des yvelines et frédéric
marc simon soir la directrice et
cofondatrice de wendake qui est basée à
saint germain en laye on rappelle que
cette association accueille accompagné
prend en charge et les femmes victimes
de violence ainsi que leurs enfants donc
on va parler du travail qui a été mené
dans les yvelines avec vous juste avant
d'en parler marylène iapichino bonsoir
de la rédaction de tv 78 dès le 3
septembre dernier date du début du
grenelle des mesures ont été annoncées
oui grégory et dès son lancement 10
mesures d'urgence ont été prises je
rappelle quelques-unes 5 millions
d'euros pour la création de 1000
nouvelles places d'hébergement d'urgence
la possibilité de porter plainte à
l'hôpital dès le 25 novembre date de fin
du grenelle la création de procureurs
référence sur la question des violences
pour que les dossiers soient traités
sous quinze jours et la mise en place
effective du bracelet entier
rapprochement après mais aussi avant
condamnation
ce dernier a d'ailleurs été adoptée à
l'assemblée le 12 octobre dernier
nous sommes donc à 20 jours de la fin de
ce grenelle au niveau national des
propositions sont déjà ressorti à
respectivement les 11 groupes de travail
composé de représentants d'associations
et de l'état de proches de victimes
d'avocats ou encore de professionnels de
santé ont réfléchi autour de plusieurs
thématiques 60 propositions ont été
remises et présenté le 29 octobre
parmi elles la mise en place d'un
protocole clair dans les commissariats
et gendarmeries pour améliorer l'accueil
des victimes avec également une grille
d'évaluation du danger l'inscription
dans la loi de toutes les formes de
violence pour ne pas oublier les
violences psychologiques et d'emprise
sur les victimes
aujourd'hui seuls les violences
physiques elle harcèlement moral sont
répréhensibles pénalement la création du
statut d'enfant aux victimes il existe
déjà un tas
d'enfants témoins mais en le
transformant en victime cela permettrait
à ce que le parent agresseurs doivent
répondre devant la justice était
préjudice causé aux enfants une
redéfinition de l'indemnisation des
victimes
pour lutter contre l'emprise économique
des conjoints violents sur leurs
victimes
enfin le renforcement de la formation
des professionnels susceptibles d'être
en contact avec des victimes de
violences conjugales
les effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie les professionnels de santé
les représentants syndicaux et les
responsables en ressources humaines au
sein des entreprises seraient concernées
par ces formations et pour les médecins
une évolution du secret médical est
envisagée avec la possibilité pour
professionnels de santé témoin de ces
violences de les porter à la
connaissance des autorités sans l'accord
de la victime
merci marianne pour toutes ces
précisions et on rappelle un ce numéro
et d'écouté gratuit et anonyme le 39 19